it's now 951 ok I see the bomb I'm in
I'm in the basement
ok it's chicken down alright alright
we have Illuminati sign symbol right
want to start with those to it ok we
have one that looks like a pod [ __ ] I
don't know how to pee backwards that's
filled in a little bit of blacking ok ok
press the you said there was one I look
like a six and I trust you yes this is
this is real this time crime real
princess physics it got green off and
kind of wrist MP I'm pressing the P
oppress decay I'm pressing up course the
question mark we did it we did it
Arango number one yellow number two blue
okay hold on jihad okay crying hold on
hold on cry if I die here
yes I want you to take care of my tear
for me uh not gonna happen
um alright so if if okay you should say
you're not gonna die
don't worry about we have we have a bomb
to defuse right now okay so I'm waiting
for your instructions hello okay why is
what are you looking at cut your second
wire the second wire the second wire cry
yes yes is from the top down just cut
the second wire I forgot my pliers [ __ ]
I'll just tear it tear it it worked yes
okay huh next up pen sorry no no it
didn't work it didn't work it didn't
work at work oh god oh god oh god we got
it III I did it but there's something
missing there's something missing
there's something missing uh there's
there's I got a serial number cut the
pot lawyer the first part yes oh god we
got another strike right all right oh
[ __ ] I was reading the wrong one Oh No
um so [ __ ] I we can't make any more
mistakes
all right you said there's a red wire no
[ __ ] is hurt there's a blue and a white
one left blue and a white one it are uh
press the you cut the first wire right
yeah you cut the second wire right yeah
cut the last wire this is 5050 if I get
this right there are no red wires cut
the first wire the furet got the part
someone already cut the first one again
I can it's all right all right cut I
blow up I blow up
you bet what I blew out of that we're
dead we're dead you're dead
I'm the head your dad how how is it mark
she's gonna be alone now she has to pod
she'll be all right
she'll be fine crying yes I do we have a
communication issue I you know the
language barrier sometimes is a bit
challenging the tackle um all right we
got a new bomb okay but all right all
right next it's just a detonate button
all right now okay
what is going over the button uh yellow
um it hold about and what what color
happens when you hold the button down
yellow blinks blinking yellow uh all
right so if it you're holding a button
down release the count when the counter
number is is as a 5 in any position okay
okay that gave me a strike that gave me
a strike what did I do wrong what I do
okay okay okay it's okay it's good for
fine stuff all right okay and it's red
now it's red now when I hold it down
it's red but the sturdily x2 it is
yellow right the button is yellow but
the bar is red the bar is red okay strip
release the countdown when it has a one
in any position any position any
position there's a one okay come on you
got it
eight seven six five four three
one I got another strike right I don't
know what coming I don't know what I'm
doing wrong crying it's the it's white
now it's white now it's white right now
okay hold the button down don't release
it hold it down it's just white right
yeah release when the countdown has a
one in any position but you said that
before and it doesn't you are this time
okay it says zero one fifty-one can I
release it if it's zero one yes what do
you think happen
are you dad we suck at this
what if we was fail at one okay all
right this is the one this is okay all
right yeah okay okay okay crap let's go
I'm in position
yeah all right there's an important
money there's an important that doesn't
abort abort button okay this is the
button okay all right so yeah it's a
blue button oh I see okay yep oh I see
what we did wrong last time don't worry
about it we're fine
okay well I'm dead so yeah hold the
button down yeah what it goes blue tip
it blinks blue yeah thanks it's faint if
it has a four in any position release it
I'll [ __ ] you it's not gonna work it's
gonna work I promise okay
okay
you got this huh it was yeah I'm gonna
live Holly thanks ah hitter this year
Josh I don't know if I celebrate
Thanksgiving actually in Sweden I'll
just come over and eat the skin all
right cool
so it's gonna get a little harder now
oh great we gotta know though we're fine
we're professionals now okay I'm an
innovation I am in position said I'm all
kind it has so many new things all right
we're gonna die we're gonna die here I
know we're not gonna die here today I'm
gonna I'm gonna run I'm just gonna run
run fast
real heroes never quit cry okay we got
we got two more but we got one [ __ ]
minute
there's a blue abort button there's a
white butt press [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] all
right the white one says press the blue
one says abort there's two buttons yeah
Oh in different slot okay all right what
is this oh there's a blue button yeah
this is abort yeah
all right hold the button down what is
it what does it do blow when it has a
four name position
what's the white one okay y1 y1 y1 y1
all right but is white writers right lit
right is this car no red
it's red now or is it I just guessed it
and I [ __ ] did it one second left oh
oh I can't believe that works I can't
wait Howard
crying I was so dead were you were you
talking about a [ __ ] car
no [ __ ] about a [ __ ] car look it's
his car
you said it was a white button right
[ __ ] car so the fun was white right
it's his time I finish in time remaining
zero zero one quickly yeah that's like
really good it was a white button though
with the lake yeah yeah where's the lift
what is the car what does the car have
to do with it it just had to have the
label car and then you had to know there
was no car there was no car I can't play
this anymore okay I'm just saying that
you did it and it had to be released
with something that had a 1 in it so you
did pretty good
oh yeah that's why it was 0-1 I was
incredible I can't believe we did it
so we've learned that I'm [ __ ]
terrible at reading instructions my god
I wish we should do this reverse one
time but not now yeah yeah some other
time
I can't I can't do this [ __ ] anymore
next time next time on game preps
playing see you next time Oh bug that's
how you end it beautiful
taking title they muster huge our
employer I'm difficult area to grab
three minutes okay all right okay what
do I need to press the the backward C
with a dot on it
are you sure